all right 10 show challenge here we go
the show that ended perfectly 10 out of
10 would not change a thing the show
that ended horribly i mean
what happened
the show that had the most potential and
then they just ruined it
the show that you think is criminally
underrated you recommend it to all your
friends you will live and die by this
show the show that was constantly
recommended to you by your friends and
you went into it with the open mind you
wanted to like it but you just couldn't
the show that you constantly have to
defend to your friends but you don't
mind you love it that much the show that
you loved as a kid and then you went
back to re-watch it when you were older
and it was just
so disappointing
the show that you know deep down your
heart that it's awful but you still love
it anyways
the show that at one point had you super
hooked but then they lost you and they
will never get you back again and
finally the best show that you haven't
watched the show that everyone
recommends to you and you're just not
ready for that type of commitment right